is you know an examination of systemic  power and how that is corrupting no  matter what your sexual persuasion or  your your your gender orientation is no  matter what your age you know it is a  force without within us as a human's a  human that can separate ourselves not  only from what we do but from ourself  and and from our relationship it's a  corrupting force and I you know and I  think that that is something that we  were we were continuingly focusing on in  a social media age I mean there's no  easy goodies there's no easy baddies  it's it's a wonderfully thrillingly  uncertain ride that the audience is  asked to go on and you know it's it's  not about conducting it's it's not about  any one particular thing so it's been  very difficult to talk about because I  don't I've never seen a film like this I  don't know how to define it you know